Speaker 1: I have said a few times now, Joe
Biden must get another major piece of legislation
done this calendar year.
Twenty, twenty one, or it's going to be a
really tough uphill battle in the midterms.
The midterms are not a foregone conclusion.
Traditionally, almost always, when a party
takes a White House in an election year, two
years later in the first midterm, they don't
do well in the midterms.
That's typically the way it goes in most cases.
I don't believe that it is necessarily going
to go that way in twenty, twenty two, but
it could.
And Joe Biden needs a major legislative accomplishment.
Fortunately for America, there has been major
progress on the infrastructure bill that Democrats
have been trying to figure out.
How on earth can we move forward on this with
Republicans?
This is great news for the country.
It's good news for Democrats, but it's apparently
disastrous news for the former president,
Donald Trump, who has blown a gasket over
this attacking Republicans.
Now, mind you, so far all that's happened
is that late last week, Republicans in the
Senate went along with starting to debate
the infrastructure bill.
They've not even voted on the package yet.
OK, they're just starting the process right
now.
That alone has Donald Trump absolutely losing
it.
Trump putting out a statement, quote, Under
the weak leadership of Mitch McConnell, Senate
Republicans continue to lose.
He lost Arizona.
He lost Georgia.
Weird.
I don't remember Mitch McConnell being on
the ballot there.
He ignored election fraud and he doesn't fight
now.
He's giving Democrats everything they want
and getting nothing in return.
No deal is better than a bad deal.
Fight for America, not for special interests
and radical Democrats.
Rhinos are ruining America right alongside
communist Democrats.
I don't know if there is anything that's accurate
in that.
It has real old man yelling at a cloud energy
to it, if you notice.
But think through the things he's saying there,
first of all.
How is it that Mitch McConnell lost Arizona
and Georgia?
It was Trump who lost Arizona and Georgia.
He was the candidate.
Mitch McConnell was on the ballot in Kentucky,
only where he won.
Now, maybe Trump is referring to Mitch McConnell's
poor leadership, led to Republican senators
losing in Arizona and in in Georgia.
I believe Trump is more responsible than Mitch
McConnell for those losses as well.
Makes absolutely no sense.
And by the way, when Donald Trump spent several
years insulting the late Senator John McCain,
who was very popular in Arizona, did that
help or hurt Trump in Arizona?
But it was somehow Mitch McConnell's fault.
Trump barely won in 2016, eked it out, just
barely winning in a few states, lost the popular
vote, insulted key people in key states, failed
on covid, alienated nearly half the country.
And he thinks it couldn't be his fault that
he and his Republican colleagues lost in Arizona
and Georgia.
And if they did, it's someone else's fault
for sure.
Like it's really, really a complete inability
to take responsibility for anything.
Now, there's a ton of words in Trump's statement
about this, but it can be translated in this
way.
I'm really mad that Republicans are going
to go along and give Joe Biden an accomplishment
because it makes me look bad because I couldn't
get infrastructure done.
That's the translation of what Trump is saying.
And it's not even just that.
Trump has been pushing Republicans to reject
the deal and not work with Democrats and Republicans,
at least for now, are signaling will do it
or we might do it.
It depends on how the debate actually goes
over the bill.
And for all the slamming Liz Cheney and others
as being rhinos, Republicans in name only,
those Republicans seem much more on the same
page with each other than with Trump on almost
every issue.
It's wild how Trump, as the outlier, gets
to call the others Republicans in name only.
So the real story here is Trump fails to see
his own involvement in the total loss of power
that Republicans have experienced.
The buck never seems to stop with Trump when
it's not convenient.
Under Trump, Republicans lost the House in
twenty eighteen.
They lost the Senate in twenty twenty.
They lost the White House in twenty twenty.
But Mitch McConnell is responsible for the
state's Trump lost and Trump actually won
anyway.
Now back to infrastructure.
I really hope that a bill gets done.
Trump is furious because the Senate reaching
an infrastructure deal under Biden rather
than under Trump, which is something he promised
to do, makes him look bad.
And that's true.
It makes him look bad.
And that's all that this is Donald Trump's
preference.
How is this patriotic?
Trump's preference is for American infrastructure
to crumble for four more years.
If it means he can get reelected and then
sign an infrastructure bill in twenty, twenty
five, he would rather infrastructure crumble
for four years than for Joe Biden to get a
bill done.
That's not patriotic.
That's just about Donald Trump.
And it's a reminder that he knows deep down
he's not a winner.
He wanted a big bipartisan agreement.
Biden is the one who's maybe going to get
it done instead.
Trump was feckless during his presidency and
he's now furious.
Bottom line, the country needs the infrastructure
deal.
It would be good for the country in and of
itself as improvements to infrastructure.
It would be good economically and it would
be good if you want to make a political analysis.
Joe Biden needs another major accomplishment
in twenty one.
Let's see how the debate goes.
Let's see whether the bill gets done and how
quickly it happens.
My sense is, particularly with the congressional
break coming up, we're probably looking at
September, October, but the fact that they're
starting to debate is a very good thing.
Make sure you're following us on Facebook,
at Facebook, dot com The David Pakman Show.
We'll have more
on this
story there.